Once you've been chosen, you can't
escape from this game. You have no choice but to die or become a god. The play is
finally starting. Let's all make peace together. That's why I
was struggling all by myself. What I want to
hear is  There was an icon, but it wasn't
cute. I forgot about the story and it just disappeared.
Everyone,
thank you for coming today. You were chosen. I was
born to make you a god. What am I supposed to be called a
god?  I don't understand.
Hey, I see a future where I become a god and have everything.
Just use that power and let's create a new world together. It's
just curiosity. It's
typical of scientists. It's strange, isn't it? I
haven't done anything wrong, so
why did this cause and effect happen?  The price of twisting power is the
misfortune that comes to you.I
don't mind being a little unhappy as long as I die here.I'm the OG of
God's miracles.